quand j'ai lu le titre du projet qui
s'appelle des cercles immense je me suis
dit ça c'est un projet génial pas pour
ce qui concerne claude nicolas ledoux
c'était peut-être pas simplement un rêve
mais plus un projet je vaux transition
ne convient plus haut face à l'axé juin
à la saline c'est traditionnellement le
mois des jardins avec la création du
nouveau demi cercle les dix anciens
jardins deviennent permanents eux aussi
pensé pour l'avenir de la planète
on l'a appelé le poteau poule c le
potager poule et donc on est on est
juste derrière les cuisines du
restaurant donc le restaurant pourra
donner ces déchets des légumes aux
poules il pourra récupérer des oeufs
pour son restaurant il pourra cueillir
les légumes frais de saison les plantes
aromatiques
donc c'est vraiment un lien que le
restaurant est en lien voilà un travail
entre la poule élevée le potager je
souhaite vraiment être le début c'est
par un laboratoire des métiers du
paysage expérimentés des fois on avoir
le droit de se tromper aussi rectifié
laboratoire et conservatoire ainsi sur
le pourtour du grand cercle
un véritable verger a été planté on a
choisi en fait 140 variétés de fruitiers
donc on l'a appelée la promenade
comestibles et on a travaillé avec un
pépiniériste
donc c'est on n'est que sur des variétés
locales donc on aura les cerisiers
d'abord et on va terminer par les coins
et les néfliers et donc l'idée c'est
d'avoir comme un grand comme une grande
horloge finalement vivante avec les
fruitiers qui vont qui vont arriver
durant la période de l'année
allez donc en sable tu dois te dit même
pas à charger puisqu'on va l'écarter un
peu après les pavés aussi chaque saison
chaque période il va se passer des
choses des floraisons comme dans tous
les jardins
mais c'est vrai qu'on invite vraiment
aussi public à être à l écoute de des
plus de choses en fait qu'on voit
peut-être plus quand j'observe
insectes quand j'observe un papillon
quand j'observe une floraison
ça dépend aussi de notre capacité à être
ému finalement par la beauté des choses
et par des sceaux simple donc voilà il
ya un grand geste spectaculaire mais
pour moi l'émotion et la surprise c'est
aussi dans les petites choses du vivant
s'il offre un regard sur le vivant qui
nous entoure le cercle immense est aussi
un message aux générations futures le
symbole de la fin d'un monde où l'on
pensait pouvoir tout maîtriser
nous avons toujours vécu jusqu'à ya pas
très longtemps avec une légion de la
maîtrise qu'ils nous aient laissé croire
qu'on dominait tout dans deux mines rien
et le co vide justement onaco ville nous
donne une excellente image de bas de
cette faiblesse en fait sont tributaires
de choses qui se passent
n'importe où ailleurs sur la planète ces
constats sa philosophie ses théories
gilles clément les tirs de son
expérience de ses voyages à travers le
monde et de la vie dans sa vallée
aujourd'hui il sait et il transmet dont
le cercle immense et ailleurs nouveau
transition ne convient plus on passe à
l'action
on change réellement et c'est ça on
change le mode de gestion du mode
économique
on va plutôt vers une économie de la non
dépense même si ceux qui nous dirigent
insiste pour qu'on soit quand on enlève
nos épargnes et n'est ce pas pour le
remettre dans l'économie de la
consommation ils le disent tous les
jours
non non c'est pas du tout intéressant il
faut lui il faut le mettre
éventuellement cet argent sur blanc dans
l'accroissement de la connaissance du
vivant et de la houle à savoir où on
habite
pour continuer à vivre et il agit d un
futur viable mais pour tout le monde moi
je vois ça pour petites filles
et
[Musique]